what do you suggest like is the main  thing to do do move forward to do  something that breaks the pattern  something extreme yeah like just get on  a train and go away for a week or  something different you have to break  pattern its pattern recognition it's  people get into ruts and you just need  to find something to break it even I  even even I did it with Wine Library I  was building a business I was like wait  a minute  I'm not a hundred percent happy I  started a video show on YouTube I did it  wasn't like I went to Africa I just  broke the pattern yeah in an extreme way  I started a new pattern and so start a  new pattern but you might not like it  but do it for 30 days and if you want to  keep doing it go and if not then start a  different pattern pattern break up yeah  that's great awesome